freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video es ist mal wieder soweit nicht wir
an meinem geburtstag durch den tollsten
tag aller zeiten essens mäßig habe ich
nämlich einen tag lang fünf sterne essen
bestellt heute bestellen wir einen tag
lang null sterne essen und falls ihr
euch fragt wie das geht null sterne
heißt ja nicht dass es super schlecht
ist null sterne ist einfach dass man
nicht bewertet ist und klar wenn ich
mega gespannt ob wir überraschung
kriegen ob wir vielleicht super eklige
sachen bekommt es ist einfach eine
wundertüte der heutige tag und damit ich
nicht allzu sehr enttäuscht werde falls
ich mal was schlechtes erwische nutze
ich heute igraal da kann ich nämlich bei
jeder bestellung cash zurück bekommen
aber keine sorge ich endlich das dazu
legen wir los
blende euch jetzt mal hier an der seite
eine übersicht ein wir gehen auch
sortieren nach vehlen bewertungen aus
und dann scrollen wir einfach ganz ganz
runter so leute wir sind angekommen wie
das direkt aus sie thomaskirche null
sterne deutsche gerichte flammkuchen
salate puncto pasta thai food am dom es
gibt so viele sachen dann adamek
frühstückskorb ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass wir ein frühstück laden finden
great sandwich um ein gut mango chia
coconut pudding und kaffee okay was
nämlich noch mit rein ich bin direkt er
sich direkt ich marschiere hierdurch ich
bestelle mir dazu noch einen manchmal
flatrate ein kleines leck kleid einfach
dazu
die akku mit ja nur alternative mich
aber dann überlege ich mal was ich gut
finde ich jetzt gerne kerschl sagte ja
kommen da nehme ich mag essen und gucken
ob das lecker wird 18 euro 20 kann man
machen für so ein frühstück aber hey das
ist ja absolutes super frühstück und
gehe es auch das konzept wird wir
stellen jetzt raus ich hab mir gute
vorahnung sage ich euch bei diesem
frühstück und wir sehen uns gleich wenn
es angekommen ist bestellt uns
angekommen wir packen erstmal aus aber
kein wunder dass ich so viel geld
bezahlt habe der gia pudding den seinem
boss mäßigen glas verpackungstechnik
hammer erinnert mich ein bisschen an das
was ich mal für drei mix gemacht
bei einem tag persönlicher koch und
jetzt hier kommen wir zum great and
which also man muss sagen wenn man sich
das ganze mal anschaut ist schon ne gute
ecke kohle sage ich natürlich dafür
eingesetzt habe aber als aller erstes
review chef den charakter ihr wisst ja
ich bin ein großer katzenliebhaber und
da bin ich gespannt wie wahrscheinlich
gerade mit cash und wasser getrunken
[Musik]
kraft ich habe den ohne sirup bestellt
und er ist trotzdem super süß richtig
geil ausbalanciert wird sich vielleicht
sogar drin zu sehen ist aber geht glaube
ich gar nicht mit dem transport sehr
lecker garantiert garantiert jetzt schon
der beste kaffee dient ihr bestellt habe
laras hinter der kamera dann probiert
jetzt auch mal echt gut und jetzt mein
das sehen wir schon das habe ich jetzt
probiert kommt die große überraschung
und wie ist das grills händisch was
kostet 7 euro oder so erwartet wird es
sind zwei ich weiß nicht ob das brioche
brot ist richies bub ist es am schönsten
doch jetzt kommt der test ganz anders
als ich gedacht habe
ich kenne die sandwiches so dass die
halt so super plain sind so viel
günstiger ich glaube die verwenden
einfach ein bisschen ausgereifteren käse
nicht ganz richtig einordnen so also auf
jeden fall sehr lecker weiß nicht ob ich
kleider von als ein klassisches pritsche
super nice superhoch relativ ganz kurz
mal danke dass das mein job ist dass ich
sowas hier mache ich es ist wirklich
sehr auf mysteriöse art und weise ist
das bild komplett verschwunden sechs
euro 80 bisschen teuer dafür muss ich
auf jeden fall sagen gucken wir uns
jetzt in china pudding an wo es richtig
rudi ist nicht so frisch an so einem
sommertag genau das richtige also ein
level wo beides drauf ist mango curry
und china bringt dass das günstiger ist
als coaches finde ich aber fahren hier
irgendwie fall irgendwie ist das so viel
mehr
ok also man checkt auf jeden fall das
ist gesund sein soll und ich wette wenn
ich das es fühle ich mich gut also auch
das sehr sehr nice ich glaube ich mache
das heute nicht so dass ich sage wie
geht es von null bis zehn ist sondern
wie viele lieferanten sterne ich gegeben
hätte und in dem fall sind es
viereinhalb von 5 also wirklich top aber
nicht 100% gleiches frühstücke ich freue
mich aufs mittagessen und jetzt erzähle
ich euch erst mal wie ich dabei fett
sparen werde so vorne wie gesagt ich
will das mal nachschauen
wie viele kohle ich hätte sparen können
weil meiner bestellung heute morgen und
dazu erzähle ich euch aber erst mal was
sie gerade überhaupt ist die
freundlicherweise dieses video
unterstützen grundsätzlich erstmal ist
igraal eine plattform die cashback
dienste anbietet mit anderen worten die
kriegen eine vermittlungsprovision dafür
dass du von der igraal homepage zu einem
partnershop gehst einem von über 1800
dafür kriegen die eine provisionen die
sie bis zu 90 prozent an dicht als
nutzer weitergeben und für mich
besonders interessant ihr wisst nicht
liebe essen zu bestellen dieses video
heute ist auch wieder wirklich ein
reiner traum perfekter weise ist
lieferando einen partnershop von igraal
deshalb gucken wir uns das ganze jetzt
gleich mal an und schauen wie viel kohle
wir sparen können bei den weiteren
bestellungen heute ihr könnt ihr dort
eigentlich auf jedem gerät benutzen also
jetzt in browser da gibt es sogar eine
app erweiterung da könnt ihr auf jeder
seite direkt checken ob wir kohle sparen
könnt und es gibt auch eine handy app
wenn ihr zum beispiel wie ich meistens
vom handy gestellt ich selbst habe
direkt vor meiner anmeldung auch in
zehner bekommen und ab 20 euro könnt ihr
euch einfach das geld auf euer bankkonto
auszahlen lassen
also es gibt eigentlich im prinzip
keinen grund egal nicht zu nutzen
ihr könnt einfach geld sparen ohne ja
ohne irgendwas zu machen und das machen
wir jetzt mal denn ich habe einfach
schon wieder hunger das wird sich so gut
anfühlten essen bestellen kohle sparen 3
prozent immerhin bei dem wie oft ich
bestelle könnte das glaube ich eine sehr
gute idee sein
die aktivieren cashback wird aktiviert
hersteller aktiviert und darf das bei
unserem spiel schnell weil auch wirklich
nicht unterschätzen ja das ist das jetzt
möglich die kur wirklich allein heute
morgen habe ich für 18 euro bestellt
sind direkt mal so 55 cent und ich
bestellt viel also das läppert sich sehr
schnell und ist einfach nur coole sachen
ich wollte mal wieder nach bewertung und
suchen wir die klassischen null sterne
restaurants aus teilen bis am
hohenzollernring an so einem schönen
sommertag dave liegt auch schon hinter
der kamera teams das kenn ich
da werde ich nicht bestellen döner
träger gibt es auch sehe ich nicht mehr
teilen bis ich hoffe dass dieses null
sterne restaurant auch überzeugen wird
bestellen also zwei gerichte zum
probieren der freut sich wahrscheinlich
auch für mich ist der klassiker
teil drei restaurants zwei gerichte drin
21.50 das heißt nach adam riese 64 15
ersparnis damit sie mir schon bei einem
euro
am ersten tag innerhalb von 48 stunden
kriege ich einfach die kohle
gutgeschrieben nicht das schmeckt dann
wirklich doppelt gut hoffentlich bin
gespannt ob es gut wird freunde grüßt
euch liegt abgerissen es ankommen und es
ging sehr flott muss ich sagen erst mal
positiv gucken wir mal rein es ist
richtig schwer ich habe viel man kriegt
hier auf jeden fall treu und ich war es
denn gerecht werden wie gesagt einmal
partei- und einmal gegen massa man weiß
nicht jeweils 10 euro
faire preise finde ich für eine für ein
ordentliches gericht sieht sehr gut aus
man sieht hier frisch geröstete erdnüsse
ist auch schon mal nice also dass die
nicht einfach nur gemalt sind oder sind
gerüstet ist limette dabei gehört es
dazu ja ich glaube wird traditionell
dazu bereit vielleicht haben sie selbst
schon die menschen daran gemacht und
werden gleich erschmecken
hier ist unser nashorn auf diese sahne
versand wird hier reis drin sein
lustig doch traumhaft ich kriege ich
richtige urlaubs weiß gerade so ist
wirklich heute ist einfach ein geiler
tag und ich probiere das perfekt es hat
so richtig diese balance von süß sauer
pudel sind auf einem sehr leichten
garten gezogen sind aber nicht die mette
gefühlt limette fehlt mir schon die ja
da muss ich dann aber es ist nicht zu
übersehen dass parteien wie man es auch
manchmal ist sehr solide wirklich sehr
lecker und ich probiere hey leute was
das für ein leben ich probiere jetzt das
master man noch direkt
camp sehr geschmacksintensiv inga
kokoschkas sahnige ich weiß gar nicht
was man bei dich lieber will also ich
glaube dadurch ich gehe auch das master
arbeit ist richtig gut ist ehrlich leute
dass man 55 uhr ist es wirklich fünf von
fünf sternen part ist meiner ansicht
nach verdient also bisher leute wirklich
das hätte auch wirklichen reinfall sein
können null sterne es könnte man weiß ja
nie aber es ist super lecker ich zähle
darauf dass die dritte bestellung heute
auch so lecker sein wird wir sehen uns
dazu ich bin ganz ehrlich zu euch leute
ich habe gestern nichts mehr geschafft
ich habe ich noch mal eine große
mahlzeit bestellen können deshalb meist
das ganze jetzt einen tag später und wir
kommen zur dritten mal zeit klagt
ehrlich leute ich glaube ihr wollt auch
dass ich das tue und ich werde jetzt bei
döner der gare stellen wow beliebte
gerichte schubschiff weiß das klingt
richtig pervers tor
ich sage ehrlich muss sich bestellen
allein dass wir mal sehen ob das cool
ist oder nicht und dazu noch ein
klassischer döner mit scharfer soße
natürlich liebe dich das video wirklich
ich will nicht als die letzte bestellung
ist aber erstmal wir haben gesehen
kleine speisekarte ist immer ein gutes
handy displays können eigentlich nur
verwertet werden die bestellung ist raus
sollte jetzt heißt es nur noch abwarten
und probieren es ist soweit freunde vor
mir steht die bestellung wir gucken
einfach mal rein
tipp für kräfte herzinfarkt aus das sind
die switches preis noch mal richtig auch
mit kampagne hier ein bisschen braun
geraten bisschen dunkel geraten ja ich
glaube ganz okay ich glaube dies merke
ich mal direkt als erstes weil da ist
natürlich die gefahren größten dass sie
sehr weich werden und dann haben wir
hier noch schöner decker nice verpackt
muss ich sagen also sieht man selten bei
denner lernen dass da so auch
verpackungsdesign geachtet wird dass ich
zumindest
wir starten direkt rein denn unsere
chips preis also allein dass es sowas
ist sotschi stückpreis ist schon
irgendwie für mich ein bisschen
ausgefallen aber wir nehmen alles auf
eine gabe des youtube capellos dabei
nach der gabe bin ich schon bin ich
schon tot
das ist verrückt das ist so verrückt der
schmücke heftig gut aber es ist so
unfassbar ungesund glaube ich die promis
natürlich nicht mehr knusprig da unten
drunter also diesen wissen durchgemacht
haben auch schon echt gut teuer muss ich
sagen für 57 verstehe jetzt auch warum
die gießener angeboten haben bei dieser
käse so sind wir haben es übel slacker
das ist wirklich gut aber schauen wir
uns den eigentlichen da der show
der döner kann schon was gar nicht so
gut sein wie die pommes bei die sind
wirklich next level das habe ich selten
gegessen so was uns in deiner hand
okay leute sagen der sieht ja fast ein
bisschen komisch aus dem bereich wir
haben den einfach nicht vernünftig
aufgeschnitten untere hälfte des döners
ist einfach nicht aufgeschnitten wird
ihr das okay ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das
absicht ist oder nicht aber prinzipiell
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen komisch so
sieht das gute stück aber auf einer
anderen perspektive ausgesagt hier unten
einfach dazu und hier oben ist wirklich
alles perfekt und ich probier's meisten
also deutlich schlechter ist die form
ist leider das brot man traut sich dumm
und dämlich daran
der döner ist nicht sehr schade ich
verstehe warum die käse dünnen angebot
an
ich habe mit dieser käse soße werde er
um einiges besser trotzdem ist das brot
wirklich nicht besonders gut aber die
haben mich halt wirklich weg geflasht
dafür dass es aber döner tee geheißen
das passt ja so ein zusätzliches produkt
ist gebe ich glaube ich dem namen vier
von fünf sternen
und das tut mir wirklich leid für diese
beiden sind so gut wenn euch das video
gefallen hat was gerne ein leichter
dankeschön auch noch mal ein idealist
natürlich auch alles und in der
beschreibung verlinkt da warst du gut
gepasst und ich sind super guter partner
ich lasse mir weiter schrecken macht's
gut